Health is the most valuable
thing we have in life,
but we tend to forget
that until we lose it.
We're living longer than ever before,
which is great,
but as an unforeseen consequence of
this is that we also spend a larger and
larger portion of our lives being sick.
Guessing old currently means
spending more time in pain.
So scientists are trying to shift the
attention of the medical community from
optimizing lifespans to
optimizing health spans.
The part of our lives during which
we're disease free. To do this,
we need to attack the root cause
of almost all bodily defects.
Aging itself unbeknown to most people,
the signs of aging has made enormous
progress in the last few years with human
trials about to begin in the near future.
Let's look at three examples
of discoveries that might
benefit people who are
alive right now.
Yeah,
one senescent cells.
Your cells have an expiration date.
Each time one of your cells divide,
it copies its chromosomes.
Because of the way this works,
they lose a tiny bit of DNA at the end.
This could be catastrophic,
so to protect themselves,
we have long segments of DNA called
telomeres that sort of act like the stiff
bits at the end of shoe laces,
but they shrink with every
cell division and some cells.
After a number of divisions,
the telomeres are gone and
the cell becomes a Zombie,
a senescent cell senescent
cells stay around and don't die.
The older you get,
the more of them there are inside you.
They harm tissue around them and are
linked to many diseases that accompany old
age like diabetes and kidney failure.
But what if you could kill them off
scientists genetically engineered mice so
that they could destroy their
senescent cells as they pleased.
Older mice without senescent
cells will more active.
The hearts and kidneys worked better
and they were less prone to cancer.
Overall, they lived up to 30% longer
and in better health than average mice.
Since we can't genetically engineered
all of the cells in the human body,
we need to find another way to
get rid of our senescent cells,
but how do we kill them
without harming healthy cells?
Most cells in the body
commit to a programmed cell
suicide when they're damaged,
but senescent cells don't.
It turns out that they under produce a
protein that tells them when it's time to
die.
So in uh,
late 2016 study mice were given
an injection of this protein.
It killed 80% of all their senescent
cells while causing almost no harm to
healthy cells.
The treated mice became generally
healthier and even regrew last hat.
As a result,
there are a number of new companies
looking at treatments involving senescent
cells and the first human trials will soon
to nad plus cells are made from
hundreds of millions of parts that are
structures, machines, messages, and the
catalysts that make reactions happen.
All these parts constantly need to
be destroyed, cleaned up and rebuilt.
As we age, this process becomes less
effective and so parts become crumpled,
bunched up,
or are removed slower or they are no
longer produced in the quantities we need.
One of these parts is Nad plus a coenzyme
that tells ourselves to look out for
themselves as age 50.
We only have about half as much in our
bodies as we do at age 20 low amounts of
it are linked to a whole bunch of
diseases from skin cancer to Alzheimer's,
cardiovascular disease
and multiple sclerosis,
but nad plus content or cells,
so we can't get it as a pill,
but scientists noticed that other more
flexible substances could enter cells and
would then turn into Nad plus end site
in 2016 multiple trials on mice show that
they boosted the multiplication of skin,
brain and muscle stem cells.
They were rejuvenated,
had a higher ability to repair their DNA
and had a slightly increased lifespan.
This even got NASA interested,
which is looking for a way to minimize
the DNA damage astronauts would be
exposed to from cosmic
radiation on Mars missions.
There are human trials
being planned right now,
but it's too soon to say if this will
boost our health span or even lifespan,
but nad plus is a serious candidate and
could become the first human anti aging
bill.
Three stem cells.
Stem cells are like cell blueprints that
sit at various places in the body and
copied themselves to produce a
steady flow of fresh young cells.
But they decline as we age.
And so we declined to without new parts.
Human bodies break in mice.
Scientists observe that as the stem
cells in their brains disappeared.
They started to develop diseases,
so they took stem cells from baby mice
brains and injected them directly into
the brains of middle aged mice.
More specifically the hypothalamus apart
that involved in regulating a lot of
bodily functions,
the fresh stem cells reinvigorated older
brain cells by secreting micro RNA is
that regulated their metabolism.
After four months,
brain and muscles worked better than those
of untreated mice and on average they
lived at 10% longer.
Another study took stem cells from mice
embryos and injected them directly into
the hearts of older mice.
As a consequence,
they had improved heart function could
exercise 20% longer and weirdly enough
their hair regrew faster.
What all of this tells us is that there
is not a single magic bullet with which
to aging. It requires a complex
array of different therapies.
We can kill off senescent
cells to clear away the junk,
give ourselves fresh new stem cells to
fill the gap all while regulating the
metabolism of the other
cells using medication.
This video comes with a big caveat.
After all these studies have
been carried out on mice,
there's no guarantee the same therapist
would work in us to the same extent,
but they are proof of concepts.
To learn more about how we can modify our
own health span, we need human trials.
We've only covered a tiny part of the
research that's being done right now and
only scratched the surface of these ideas.
The field of health span extension
needs more attention and funding.
If it gets it. All of us might
enjoy growing old without pain.
If you now want to support the
research on aging directly,
you can do sober lifespan.io a community
of people actively supporting the
scientists working to cure aging.
Check them out to learn about the latest
advances and visit their blog or group
on Facebook.
The lifespan team also kindly supported
the creation of this video with a
donation and their expertise.
If you want to help us make more of our
videos, you can do so on patrion.com.